for me one of the hardest things about
having a friend incarcerated is the fact
that when i want to talk to him i can't
we're so used to being able to just snap
a picture and text it to somebody
we can't share that kind of information
with inmates
i am an artist
and i'm also the owner and director of
flipbooked llc
when you're serving a sentence you miss
out on a lot of the day-to-day
activities
being able to see a clip of video of
your family and friends can make a huge
difference
but we can't share that kind of
information with inmates
the flipbooks i do take your video and
turn it into something tangible that you
can hold
basically four to six seconds worth is
enough to make a nice length of flip
book and when an inmate gets a flip book
they can see a brief moment into the
lives of the people they love
you can say a lot in 30 sheets of flip
book it's it's really cool
i've been incarcerated in the state of
colorado for about 13 years
the hardest part of doing time is being
separated from the people you care about
they said they were going to send me a
gift and i didn't know what it was going
to be and i got a sheet of
all these little pictures and then i
understood what it was
this was the first one
it was a little dog playing in the mud
dog joy
pure unadulterated dog joy
it was a treat
to be able to sort of get a video you
know in a way
i think it's easy to understand
why flipbooks can be so powerful for the
inmates
but sometimes i feel like it might
almost be more powerful for the families
involved
being able to take just a few seconds to
capture some video that you know is
going to end up in the hands of the
person you love
is a very powerful thing